hello guys I'm Ryan right I'm Brianna
way Briana and I are gonna check out the
official trailer number one for the
Ratchet and Clank movie it's been highly
demanded I guess horse when the [ __ ] was
the last Ratchet and Clank video again a
long time ago yeah decent enough time
ago that's kind of surprising in that
they're choosing to adapt this one but I
guess it can work as a movie format I
can see kids loving this character
well yeah it's because it's so much
about like traveling the universe and
fighting crime and you got like got a
sidekick that's also a backpack it's
kind of like Dora the Explorer's yeah
and then you got like you got this
feline who's you know like it's an
animal talking animal and you got a
whole mixture okay you know what yeah I
can see how this to work I can see how
this will work
PG some rude humor though make a dick
joke
[Music]
in another world crisis in quark
galactic Rangers they're looking for a
new recruit a man with a dream actually
I'm one that's fine alum backs with a
dream then you have what it takes
you don't have what it takes God will
discover a beautiful friendship
maybe not beautiful but definitely
attractive like a stone oh yeah Frank
nice on the dark side of the universe in
two days time the Galactic Rangers will
be destroyed Stanley are you texting
[Music]
and unstoppable evil most of the time
we'll give them the chance and attack is
coming I must warn the Rangers I can
totally help to be heroes
no no legends what wait even better
anyone else feel like we should have
shot something by now I'm wrong joy oh
when a galactic force threatens the
world I'm coming here test your gear
find your courage
[Music]
nice the sudden cessation of velocity
did not cause either of you what's he
called lazy a lumberjack a lamb burro a
long brought someone that lure box you
letter box that movie looks like a lot
of funny I mean I'm watching this
trailer knowing like okay this this
doesn't look like some half-assed video
game adaptation cartoon like this looks
like a legit like DreamWorks Animation
kind of I don't know I don't know who
actually produced this I was wondering
that one it looks like DreamWorks its
Gramercy and rainfall Raintree yeah I
don't know what that production studio
is you know like the only other one I
said this about was Angry Birds but I
feel like this one could be the defining
right great video game yeah for like
video and movies because it's like we've
tried real-life video game movies it's
like why don't we try animated now and
yeah so we got angry birds coming out we
got Ratchet and Clank two very different
games however they're both like comedy
themed double family friendly oriented I
can see how this would be a great start
to unleashing more movies and it looks
like it's honoring that I imagine the
creators of the game were really
involved it looks like it yeah it really
does like beyond the look it's like they
have the tone the style the the breaking
the fourth wall along exactly yeah some
of the like comedic aspects of it yeah
yeah I want I want a lot of their random
sexual innuendos it kick some asteroid
kicks kick some asteroid it was like the
closest they had I think they could do
better
yeah I'm looking forward to more if you
look at the original Ratchet and Clank
titles for a lot of the games before
they have changed them they were like
we're like pretty nice I'm fine you're
fine some booty here
yeah what's called foreplay yeah friends
with benefits
yeah I want more than any window I like
the breaking the fourth wall it's like
kind of meta and that's just smart in
general cuz the movie can be for kids
and for adults like Shrek was a great
example of that you know there was so
many not kids jokes in there but the
kids didn't know so it was okay
the fight sequences I would have liked a
little bit more from the trailer because
the tease is we got to the fight scenes
look really cool yeah they did but I
mean that's kind of the point of a good
trailer right yeah asked have you asking
for more yeah yeah I just want to make
sure before I go in there that I'm like
at least the actions gonna be really
cool here's what I'm worried about
with a lot of kids movies and a lot of
trailers in general they have their
funniest moments in the actual trailer
so while I'm excited to see this I
always am a little bit wary of that yeah
I mean because the trailer wasn't
hilarious I thought it was really funny
those really started with inner world
and then a destroyed that world they
were like in another world
no it's it's funny and it's funny but
it's not clever it's not like like I'm
like cracking up it's but it still looks
like a fun movie I mean for the
demographic they're going for it looks
like it is on par with like great films
in that category yeah I'm definitely
gonna see it movies are my favorite
really listen every kid's favorite movie
is Cloudy with a Chance of Meatballs
really and that's not my favorite kids
movie that's my favorite movie is it
because you were late with that in real
life like sometimes you really want it
no it's hilarious it's starring Bill
Hader and a Farris it has Neil Patrick
Harris as the monkey like it's it's
hilarious
wait you Branagh you interrupted my sex
joke I'm sorry go ahead okay this is one
of your favorite movies because you can
relate with the idea of how when you
want to eat some balls your thoughts get
a little cloudy that was horrible you
shouldn't have let me say I was a really
bad one well guys new to the channel you
can subscribe today and become a reject
ibadah nightís
it's it is a disease it is a disease
it's especially it's a sexually
transmitted disease that Ryan Wright has
created it's a very unique one you can
only obtain this STD from me what's a
little better yeah who's a little better
no wasn't better no all right no one
wants to be in itis you right that's
there's no sex joke there could follow
Brianna's channel the sibling rivalry
gaming channel you should check it out
it's a lot of fun you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram Twitter vine and
periscope that's the one shout out
Youssef Erik OTT a beard I make funny
youtube gaming videos wouldn't you know
wouldn't you know another gamer over
here Brown guy plays GTI GTA 5 online
beautiful octane a Lamborghini hope you
guys give me a shoutout
youssef Erica a beard listen dude I'm
not gonna be racist right now but here's
what I will say your name back with your
voice and not knowing what you look like
makes me suspicious of you like I said I
don't want to be racist but I feel like
he's the kind of guy that would get
checked at a security airport if you
know what I mean he can say that cuz
look at him wearing a beanie yeah I got
a beard I know I look like all the guys
that we got checked it out it's not
racist cuz it also questioned him I mean
I get it I have been like like ten
people go ahead and I show up and
they're like hold on a second you know
what's funny is I always go through
those things too I'm like the anti
profile well they just want to touch you
they're just trying to prove that
they're not profiling so they pick the
whitest blond describe a city you're
just trying to Pat you down well that
happens too and you know I kind of like
it
don't we all you do don't we all wow
this is a new side to you I've seen
listen man you keep up with the gaming
videos gaming videos and Let's Plays
there's not enough of them there's like
nobody on there same thing with reaction
channels there's not enough reaction
shortage there's a shortage of reactions
and Let's Plays Breanna and I know this
from our field that we are endeavoring
in YouTube